Really?
You clicked on this?
You know this is "Pluto Nash", right?
This is, like, one of the biggest box office bombs that ever existed.
I'd much rather you watch a video on the sidescroller than put me to work for this.
It's really okay. I won't mind! There's lots more interesting videos. Look!
There's Cinema Snob reviewing...
"How Naked Kirk Cameron Saved Naked Mike Myers on Naked Christmas".
The twist is, it's really Naked Kwanzaa.
Wouldn't you much rather watch that?
(sigh) Okay.
If you're so insistent, let's go ahead and take a look at this stinker.
TAMARA: Haha, woohoo!
- Day off, baby!
- Yes!
CRITIC: No. No, guys...
...they're watching the video.
They are?
But... they know it's "Pluto Nash", right?
That's what I told them, but they're still watching.
TAMARA: But, we were gonna get drunker than...
...someone who watched "Pluto Nash"!
CRITIC:  Yeah, I know, but they wanna see a review of it, so get in your costumes!
- Thanks a lot, dickholes.
You can take your love of Eddie Murphy and shove it up your ass!
CRITIC: Funny. Most Eddie Murphy movies don't stop a drinking bender,
they usually start them.
Known as the most expensive, yet lazy, comedic bomb...
...since Netanyahu spoke at the U.N.,
"Pluto Nash" lacks any sort of charm, originality,
and yes, even comedy in what's supposed to be a charming, original, and comedic film.
This movie is put on God knows how many "worst films ever" lists,
and in many respects, I can understand.
But in others, it just doesn't seem worth the effort.
Hell, they didn't even put the effort in to convert it to Blu-Ray, they care so little!
It's so not worth the effort, I am literally phoning in this review right now.
Yeah! I'm not even here! I'm not wasting my time on this shit!
I'm actually preparing for the next review.
I swear this isn't a clue...
So let's start off with the joke I know you're all waiting for me to make...
- Trust me, this is trying harder than anything in the film.
- This is "Pluto Nash".
CRITIC: After reading a slew of actors thinking to yourself 'Oh yeah, they were a thing because they were in that... thing.'
we see Jame Moore doing horrible as a musician at a bar.
How do we know he's doing bad? Because he has an accordian, of course!
Apparently, we still like this nerdy cliche.
Oh, what, was the taped-up glasses, bow tie, and holding books musician not available?
okay this is a tough one because as of the date
this review is coming out i don't know if this incredibly clever or incredibly dated.
so, for the first time ever i am giving you a multiple choice joke!
Just come back after November 8 and choose
from one of these options.
Well they can obviously throw that prop in the fire
it wouldn't be the first time she felt the burn.
Well she bought the rest of Hollywood to get the Presidency
Are we really surprised by this?
Und get to building the Wall!!
Pluto turns them down and asks his body guard android,
played by Canada's most dangerous criminal: Randy Quaid,
to escort them out.